the movie opens with a fishing boat
captain named Baker Dill who is sailing
on Plymouth island with his sailor Duke
accompanying them are two patrons eager
to partake in the martime adventure
however Baker is so obsessed with
catching an evasive giant Yellow Fen
tuna that he denies the customers the
opportunity to handle the fishing rod
when the customers insist Baker gets
aggressive and pulls out a knife
threatening them to stay away as a
result of this the patrons refuse to
make any payment adding to the setback
Baker once again fails to catch the elus
of fish all of this is observed by a guy
named Reed from a distance who then
crosses the water in a suit to meet
Baker however his effort proves futile
as he isn't noticed by Baker after the
unsuccessful fishing trip the customers
leave without paying causing concern for
Duke regarding his compensation
nonetheless Baker knows where he can get
the money he then goes to his female
friend Constance and after spending some
intimate time together she lends him the
money he needs before parting ways he
asks about constant's son as he's
thinking of replacing Duke with him
later on Baker visits a bar owned by a
guy named Jack and shares details about
the elusive yellow funa which he refers
to as Justice through their conversation
we learn that it's his fourth
unsuccessful attempt to catch this fish
afterwards Baker goes to pay Duke and
instructs him to arrive early the next
morning he also mentions that they won't
be taking any customers this time Duke
doesn't think it's a good idea to waste
gas on a Leisure trip when they're
already short on cash but Baker doesn't
seem to care as night falls Baker drinks
alone while reminiscing about his son
Patrick and the memories they had spent
together in the past simultaneously
Patrick who is currently at his mother's
home gazes at a photo of himself and his
father cherishing the same Memories the
following morning Baker and Duke set off
for their sale unaware that Reed is
watching from a passing bus despite
spending an entire day at the sea they
find no sign of justice and are
compelled to return empty-handed again
Baker vents his frustration on Duke
blaming him for bringing Misfortune
since his wife's passing this accusation
fills Duke with anger prompting him to
walk away without a retort later in the
evening Baker heads to Jack's bar to
have a drink while there the ladder
advises him to see a therapist citing
concerns about his behavior with
customers and his Relentless obsession
with Justice however Baker simply
brushes it off amidst their conversation
he is unexpectedly approached by his
ex-wife Karen who requests a private
conversation Baker takes her to his boat
after which she tells him about the
abusive nature of her current husband
Frank she reveals that he is constantly
tormenting her and Patrick she then
addresses Baker by his real name John
highlighting his military background and
past achievements upon hearing her
problems Baker suggests getting a
divorce but she claims that escaping is
not an option due to Frank's influential
connections furthermore she tells him
about Patrick's fear during their fights
and how he uses video games as a
distraction Karen also clarifies that
she's asking for his help just to save
Patrick if Patrick has video games he
doesn't need saving she then reveals her
intention to organize a sailing trip on
Baker's boat she offers him $10 million
in exchange for getting Frank drunk and
throwing him to the Sharks however he is
uninterested in such a drastic scheme so
he asks her to leave meanwhile Reed
rushes toward the dock in an attempt to
meet Baker but it's too late as he sails
away in the morning Baker returns home
with a lot of fish to sell only to find
constant waiting for him there she
expresses curiosity about Karen after
overhearing their conversation the
previous night however Baker opts not to
disclose anything and goes for a swim
instead as soon as he dives into the
ocean he starts hearing voices of
Karen's husband yelling at her and
Patrick Baker also has a vision of his
son swimming beside him but when he
attempts to reach out he abruptly wakes
up at his home's table sensing the wet
surface simultaneously Patrick comes out
of his blanket after his gaming session
and discovers spilled water on his desk
this indicates that there is a
mysterious connection between them
either that or they're both just having
wet dreams like father like son on the
same day Frank arrives at the island
surprising Karen while she's in the
bathroom wasting no time he instructs
her to remove her bathrobe so that he
can inspect her body when he finds a
little scratch he takes off his belt to
punish her in the next scene Baker heads
to a fishing store owned by a woman
named Lois he is here to settle his
debts and purchase some new hooks Lois
tells him that the entire island is
aware of Karen's suffering from Frank's
abusive Behavior she also mentions
Reed's search for but he leaves without
paying much attention upon reaching the
dock Baker finds Caren and Frank already
waiting for him despite Frank's
insistence on joining the planned
fishing trip Baker declines citing the
absence of a sailor and emphasizing that
it goes against regulations however
Frank believes that everything has a
price and Promises to return the next
morning for the trip before departing he
Reveals His gun and instructs Baker to
be there before him undeterred by this
our hero sets sail once more in pursuit
of Justice Just then Reed arrives at the
dock but misses him again Reed sucks
upon checking his watch he discovers a
20-second discrepancy in his allotted
schedule Baker's Quest For Justice
remains unsuccessful but he manages to
catch some valuable stuff to sell at the
market he then spends the night with
Constance who presents him with a moral
dilemma saving a woman or catching the
elusive tuna however Baker completely
ignores her and heads to the market the
next morning there Duke approaches him
having heard about the 10 million offer
for the fishing trip he emphasizes the
urgent need for money to help his
grandson and refurbish their boat vot
Serenity recognizing this as a very good
opportunity Baker finally agrees to take
Frank on the trip following this the two
go to the dock where Frank and Karen
have already arrived Baker privately
informs her that he'll only take Frank
fishing and do nothing more Karen still
attempts to change his mind by
describing how her husband harms their
son she also reveals that Patrick can
hear them through his computer screen
wait what that seemed important but
Baker is unfaced he then proceeds on the
sale with the other men during the trip
Frank starts talking about at his
stepson he addresses Patrick as creepy
because the boy always stays in his room
playing video games and shows no
interest in other sports their
conversation is suddenly interrupted
when a shark takes the bait and Baker
allows Frank to reel it in in the
process the ladder slips on the deck but
manages to recover safely in the next
scene they make their way back to the
dock and Karen appears disappointed to
see her husband again she speaks with
Baker in private presenting him with the
same offer as Frank will want to fish
again she also asserts that it is
Patrick's idea so he should do it for
the sake of their son after they leave
Duke confronts Baker as he has heard
their conversation he asks about what's
going on and Baker reluctantly reveals
the entire Story upon learning
everything Duke reminds him of his
inherent goodness asserting that taking
someone's life is not in his nature
instead he encourages him to keep
focusing on the pursuit of justice that
night Baker retreats to his boat to do
some thinking when Karen approaches him
in the Heavy Rain inside the boat she
reveals a ring Baker gave her at the age
of of 16 expressing that she hasn't
forgotten him and that she's still the
same girl she used to be their
conversation eventually takes a romantic
turn and they end up having kidus during
this Baker notices bruises on her back
and realizes that they're both damaged
in different ways as they're done he
says that he will accept her offer but
only if she brings Patrick to him Karen
thinks for a while and eventually agrees
unfortunately Frank is probably killing
Patrick right this moment later when
Baker returns home he finds Reed waiting
for for he introduces himself as a
technical representative and head of
regional sales of a fishing supply
company named Fontaine Baker wonders why
he came at 230 in the morning to which
he explains that he tried to meet him
numerous times during the day but missed
him every time Reed who is well aware of
Baker's Mission the next day offers him
a free trial of the newest Sonic fish
finder he also discourages him from
harming anyone this alerts Baker so he
brandishes his knife and questions how
he knows so much about him Reed then
reveals that he's just a participant in
a game called called Plymouth Island
that offers various options the
Creator's personal favorite among the
options is fishing the game's objective
is to catch a specific fish which aligns
with Baker's Obsession however Reed is
perplexed about the altered rules as the
initial rule dictated that nobody dies
in Plymouth Baker then abruptly wakes up
in his bed unable to move until the
alarm goes off upon getting up he
recalls his conversation with Reed the
previous night he then examines a couple
of maps only to discover that Plymouth
island is situated in the middle of
nowhere after this Baker drives to a
remote area in an attempt to communicate
with Patrick confessing his intention to
harm Frank he admits to having no
recollection of memories except for
fishing with his son and lying down
lifeless on the sand his Reflections are
suddenly interrupted by constant's son
Samson who's left his previous job to
work for him on the boat although Baker
considers his presence as a positive
sign he refuses to Grant him Duke's job
because the rules have changed now
following this Baker proceeds to call
Reed but he's interrupted by Lois who
invites him into her shop she presents
him with a box of fishing supplies left
by Reed as a complimentary sample all of
a sudden Baker asks her about their
location on Earth but the latter is
unable to answer this evading the
question she wishes him a good day and
advises him to do what is right when he
seeks clarification on what is right for
him Lois simply urges him to go catch
the fish Baker then makes a brief call
to the Fontaine Office to verify their
authenticity but he quickly hangs up
after expressing his gratitude later he
meets with Jack and bombards him with
several questions however the latter
doesn't know how to answer them either
confirming that they're all NPCs here
it's revealed that the entire movie is
depicting the gaming World created by
Patrick in remembrance of his father
turns out that Baker was actually killed
in action after which his wife married
Frank why Patrick programmed his
stepdad into this game is
anyone's guess meanwhile in the hotel
room Karen discovers that someone has
attacked Frank causing him to bleed
despite his injury she still encourages
him to go fishing even offering to join
him for assistance on the boat Duke
reveals that he has paid some thugs to
harm Frank he has done this to rescue
Baker from his temptation however this
only enrages our guy and ends up kicking
Duke off of his boat afterwards he comes
across Reed who inquires if he knows the
creator of the game Baker knows it's
Patrick but he says that it's a boy who
is wishing to reunite with his father in
the next scene he makes his way to his
boat where Karen and Frank are already
waiting they then get on board and start
preparing for the trip later as Baker
and Karen are strategizing their plan
Samson unexpectedly appears on the boat
surprising them both this complicates
matters as pushing Frank into the ocean
with the boy watching is no longer an
option moments later Samson loudly
announces the capture of a large fish on
their bait when Baker hurries to handle
the fishing rod he realizes that it's
Justice the one he has been obsessed
with despite this he takes this as an
opportunity to execute their plan and
hands the rod to Frank The Boy Who is
too weak to handle the powerful fish is
pulled into the water He Is tragically
killed but his death is made to look
like an accident simultaneously Patrick
hears Frank yelling at Karen prompting
him to leave his room with his father's
knife a few moments later he returns
with blood on his hands following this
the news of Patrick stabbing his
stepfather in the chest spreads
throughout the country Karen delivers an
explanation stating that Patrick acted
in self-defense she also reveals that
they have been victims of domestic abuse
ever since Patrick's biological father
was killed in action back on the island
as Karen prepares to leave she tells
Baker that both she and Patrick love him
she also assures him that he'll be able
to reunite with his son one day shortly
after her departure Baker answers a call
at a phone booth and speaks to Patrick
who confesses his actions and Promises
to alter the game so that they can meet
as soon as the call ends Baker notices
that the environment around him is
starting to change not long after
Patrick is seen running toward his
father finally the two have a joyful
reunion and the movie ends as they sail
into the sea for a fishing Expedition
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out thank you for
watching